Guedelon is a somewhat crazy adventure
in the heart of the Burgundian forest
for about twenty years we
decided to build to understand a
13th century fortified castle
the 13th century in france and a
fabulous period no one had ever
built a  we in our
contemporary world of 13th century castle
so the first stone the last
tile we will have to learn
we are a team of 70 people
including about forty who build
castle fort because we announce and 25 years and that
with this team
nothing is impossible and the
wildest dreams without realizable
so guennelon it is different from
other castles in the world
simply because it was
made in the 21st century with means
that are medieval
with techniques that have eight hundred
years
I did about ten years of
construction site do you like little everywhere in France
so compared to guedelon with what
I did before it will be difficult
because
Guedelon is a site that is unique
in fact it is science
and archeology and that suits me well
it is a return to history that I
find interesting each small stone
has been cut
each piece of wood has  been shot by
hand and carys by hand drawn by hand
by a fabulous team so that's
magnificent and so there's an
incredible energy there others that I find
completely moving and we have a real
castle in celebration and that
We made it so I'm
still super proud of what we're doing and
it's still a great adventure